super bowl sunday is just days away but  for some uh  the big event has for something that has  a big event has little to do with  football and lots to do with puppies of  course the annual puppy bowl returns for  the 18th year where teams rough and  fluff will bring the canine action ahead  of the other big game this year's show  features a record 103 puppies and nine  pairs of puppy siblings from 51  different shelters across the u.s and of  course solve for a good cause to raise  awareness and encourage people to adopt  from shelters and rescues here's a sneak  peek  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  my goodness  and the rep is gonna have to step in for  this one  hey moby  moby moby listen that's a lot of talk  and smack for someone who hasn't scored  a touchdown i'm just saying pal